>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Thank you so much for joining us.
This is the first even online conference for
the Library of Congress and for educators.
We have a fabulous program
lined up for you right now.
During this session, you'll learn how
to use free online assessments designed
by the Stanford History Education
Group that incorporate documents
from the Library of Congress's archives.
Participants will examine assessments,
rubrics, and sample students' responses.
Leading us through this session
is Joel Breakstone.
Joel co-directs the Teaching With Primary
Sources Program at Stanford University.
And directs the Stanford
History Education Group.
Along with Mark Smith and Sam
Wineberg, he led the development
of Stanford History Education Group's
assessment website, Beyond the Bubble.
He received his PhD from Stanford
Graduate School of Education.
And before coming to Stanford, he
taught high school history in Vermont.
So I'm going to turn things over to Joel.
>> Thanks so much, Kathy.
I really appreciate the introduction.
I'm really pleased to be
with all of you this evening.
And I want to also just reiterate
my thanks to the Library
of Congress for organizing this conference.
It's a really excellent opportunity
for teachers,
and we're really excited to
be able to participate in it.
My colleague, Sam Wineberg, just
finished up a session that perhaps some
of you had a chance to hear him speak as well.
Over the course of the next 40 minutes
or so, I hope to give you an introduction
to the materials that we've created and have
posted online on beyondthebubble.stanford.edu.
And to not only provide introduction to the
materials, but also to provide a bit of a window
into the process by which we designed
them and what we hope they are useful for.
But before I get to that, I want to just say a
little bit about how I ended up doing this work
and being at the Stanford
History Education Group.
I was a -- as Kathy mentioned -- a
high school history teacher in Vermont.
But I came to that position after
being a history major in college.
And I graduated from college
and I didn't have a job.
And I ended up getting offered a position in
Vermont, even though I had only spent a day
in Vermont before getting the job.
I moved there from Boston
-- I had grown up in Boston.
And I took over for a gentleman who had
been teaching for a number of years.
And the main things that I inherited were
a classroom set of the American Pageant.
And I knew that although the textbook would
be a great starting place for my students,
it wasn't the only thing that I wanted my
students to read in their history class.
And so I wanted them to read primary sources.
That is what I read as a history major.
And so I gave my students a document.
One of the first ones I gave them was this
great speech by William Lloyd Garrison
in which he describes the hypocrisy of
celebrating the fourth of July in independence
when there are thousands and thousands
of people enslaved in the United States.
And I found quickly that giving a
student a document that is 850 words long
and in 12-point font at 7:37
in the morning is a bad idea.
And it was that terrible feeling that
I had too often as a young teacher
where the lesson's going poorly and you're
trying to figure out how you can salvage it
so that it goes a little better when you have to
teach it three more times the rest of the day.
And so I figured out some things over the
course of my time teaching in Vermont.
But I also had a lot of questions
about how I could do the work better.
And how you could provide
more materials for teachers.
Because it's simply unreasonable to expect
that each teacher is going to be able
to create a variety of document-based
materials on their own.
It's an incredibly time-consuming process to
track down materials and to build lessons.
Certainly you can do some, but it's really
difficult to create an entire curriculum.
And so that's what led me ultimately to pack
up my life's belongings into a Penske truck
and drive across I-80 to California, where I
began a doctoral program at Stanford working
with folks who had similar interests at
the Stanford History Education Group.
Around, how do you create
materials that are available
for teachers to use with their students?
And make them in an accessible fashion
so that you don't have the looks
that my students gave me
that first morning at 7:37
where they simply had no interest in reading.
And in many cases the materials
were simply inaccessible for them.
And when I arrived at Stanford,
we had just released the Reading
Like a Historian curriculum online.
And we had a lot of interest in it.
There was a lot of excitement
about the materials.
But there was also simultaneously
a lot of talk about assessment.
And it came from the highest
levels of government.
Barack Obama, in March of 2009 said,
"I'm calling on our nation's governors
and state education chiefs to
develop standards and assessments
that don't simply measure whether
students can fill in a bubble on a test,
but whether they possess 21st Century skills
like problem solving and critical thinking."
And we agreed.
We said, yes, absolutely.
We would love to see those types of assessments.
But where are they?
That's an excellent goal,
but if you're a teacher,
where do you get those types of materials?
And simultaneously we were
releasing, as I mentioned,
the Reading Like a Historian curriculum.
This is our old website.
And when we first released the
curriculum, we got a lot of emails
from folks who began to use the materials.
And the most common query was, where
are the World History materials?
Which was a fair critique.
We've since adjusted and have begun
to make World History materials.
But the second most common
response that we heard
from people was, where are the assessments?
If you guys are going to make
all these materials based
around teaching historical inquiry and having
students engage in disciplinary reading
and thinking, how do I know whether
or not my students can do it?
How do I know whether or not they
can consider source information?
Where did the document come from?
What was the context in which it was created?
How does the context in which it was
created shape the content of the document?
These historical things need scales of
sourcing, contextualization, and corroboration.
Which our curriculum was based on.
And then at the same time the
Common Core standards were released.
And they called for students to do things
like analyze primary and secondary sources.
Consider authors' perspectives.
Corroborate sources.
And develop written historical arguments.
And we said, you know, these
are some interesting skills.
But how are we going to assess whether
or not our students can do that?
These various fairly complex ways of thinking
and reading, where are the assessments
that would help students to engage in --
to give teachers feedback about whether
or not their students can engage in
these ways of thinking and reading.
And so we continue to ask the
question, where are the assessments?
But we didn't have a good
answer for where to find them.
And when you look around, you
can find an enormous number
of materials that talk about assessments.
And particularly issues of formative assessment.
How do you create short tasks?
If you go on Amazon you can find
hundreds and hundreds of resources
that you can buy about formative assessment.
But there are not many for history teachers,
for guidance for how do you create short tasks
that give us quick feedback that we can use to
quite literally form our next steps in teaching.
There wasn't much guidance.
And moreover, there weren't many resources
in the world of formative assessment.
So we weren't sure what these types
of assessments could look like.
But we knew where we could find the
materials to make those assessments.
We had just joined the Library of Congress's
Teaching With Primary Sources Consortium.
And as a result, we suddenly had
access to the world's greatest library.
And all the resources that
the Library's archives offer.
And so we knew we wanted to
construct some short tasks
that would provide teachers meaningful feedback
about these ways of historical reading.
But we still weren't sure
exactly what form they would take.
And so we wanted to be clear
first about what are the resources
that are immediately available
to history teachers?
And we see them as existing
on a continuum of complexity.
At one end of this spectrum
are multiple choice questions,
which are quite familiar to us as teachers.
But also as citizens of the United States.
The United States likes multiple
choice questions more than most places.
In the U.K. They call multiple
choice questions "the American form."
So not everywhere has the same
fascination with multiple choice questions.
And so before we -- we knew that
multiple choice questions were available,
but we wanted to also be very clear about,
what is it that a multiple choice
question requires our students to do?
And it was an important first
step in the design process.
We wanted to be very explicit about the skills
and knowledge that are required for students
to answer a multiple choice question.
And so here's an example drawn
from the California State Test
for tenth graders, World History.
And what I'd like you to do is to take a moment,
read the question, and just think about all
of the things that a student would
need to know and be able to do
in order to answer this question.
So when we give a student
this multiple choice question,
what is it that we're really assessing?
And so as you think about that, take a moment
and just type in the chat box some of the skills
that are required in order
to answer this question.
We'll take a minute or two to do that.
And then we'll go on as people
begin to fill in some of the things
that are required in order
to answer the question.
Think of sort of the most basic thing.
What's the first thing students need to do?
And then what are some of the
knowledge that they need to know?
[ Silence ]
Great. So looking through this
list, you know, I see a lot of --
there are a lot of things that are
required in order to answer this.
You know, one of the very basic things
is it requires reading comprehension.
Students need to be able to
read and decode the question.
So somebody wrote down academic
vocabulary, right?
Students need to know what an outcome is.
And then beyond that, there are
some crucial vocabulary words.
Like "colonial possessions."
You need to know what a Communist is.
"Dominant military powers."
"International superpowers."
So there's some just reading comprehension.
There's also content knowledge, right?
Issues of, how does World War II end?
Right? Students need to know something
in order to answer the question.
And also how to read a test, right?
That there's also a basic move of test taking.
Of eliminating, somebody said,
the wrong answers, right?
It's that, you know, by the
time a student's in tenth grade,
they've taken a lot of multiple
choice questions.
They have a pretty good idea
of how to answer the question.
And so that's about doing
a process of elimination.
And so, you know, when we think about multiple
choice questions, we see them as providing,
you know, immediate feedback
about students' reasoning.
But it's not necessarily the
way to measure all of the things
that we want our students
to know and be able to do.
Because it's also measuring some things
that are not particularly historical.
Like process of elimination.
That's not a move of a historian.
That's a test-taking move.
Similarly, it doesn't give us a lot of feedback
about students' more complex ways of thinking.
But it's quick and we can do it fairly
efficiently and get some immediate feedback.
But it may not be the best tool
for measuring all of the things
that we want our students
to know and be able to do.
At the other end of the spectrum are
DBQ's -- a much more complex, rich task.
One that has gained increasing popularity
as the Advanced Placement program has grown.
And the State of New York has
used them in their Regents Exams.
And other groups have provided
materials around DBQ's.
And it's a much richer task, one that requires
students to engage in a variety of skills.
And again, what we did before we moved
on to develop the assessments was,
we wanted to be really clear about, what do some
of these most common types of
tasks require students to do?
So here's an example; this is pulled
from the 2010 AP U.S. History exam.
And it was, "In what ways did ideas and values
held by Puritans influence the political,
economic, and social development of the New
England colonies from 1630 through the 1660's?"
Students then receive a series
of primary sources.
In this case they received ten documents.
They have then an hour to read through the
documents and formulate an analytic essay,
and to compose that analytic essay.
And so again, I'd like us to take a
moment and do the same thing that we did
when we were initially surveying the field.
And take a moment and list in the chat box,
what are the things that students have to do
from start to finish in order to answer a DBQ?
So that we can have some clarity
about, what are the skills
that we're really assessing
with this type of question?
[ Silence ]
Yes, as this chat box indicates,
it's a lot of things, right?
I think that's indicative of
the complexity of the task.
Students have to, at a basic level, be able
to have some strong reading comprehension.
They need to first unpack this slide.
This is not a small thing.
You know, you need to understand this question.
What are the different pieces of the question
that need to be addressed in a response?
And then they need to engage with the documents.
And as people's comments have noted, there are
a variety of things the students have to do.
They have to skim, they have
to look for context clues.
They need to look for evidence, right?
They need to figure out what is the
argument that they're going to be making,
and then seek it out in the documents.
And as several people noted, it's
also about a process of multi-tasking.
You need to be reading at the same time
as thinking how the documents connect
to the broader argument that
they're seeking to make.
And then they need to read a map.
They need to understand archaic English.
So they're -- and the ultimately, after
they've done all this reading, and analyzing,
and organizing, they need to write.
And write pretty furiously.
In the process, hope their wrist doesn't cramp
up, they can mop some sweat off their brow,
and maybe do a quick proofread
before they're done in about an hour,
within the framework of the traditional AP DBQ.
It's a rich task.
And it is testing the types of things we want
our students ultimately to be able to do.
To analyze a series of primary documents,
and to write an analytic argument.
That's what we want our students
to be able to do.
However, it may be a little too
challenging for some students.
And moreover, its complexity
can make it a little difficult
to discern what a student is doing well at,
and the things that students
might be struggling with.
If a student doesn't do well on a DBQ,
is it because that they don't
have the reading ability?
Or is it perhaps because they struggle to
orchestrate these various skills all at once?
Or perhaps they don't do well with a timed task?
So as a result, if I'm a teacher and I receive
the DBQ back, it can be a little more difficult
to figure out, what are my next
steps to help my student do better?
In addition, though, is the issue of time.
If I'm a teacher and I assign
a DBQ, I then have to do what?
I have to grade it.
And that's really time consuming.
And unless you want to spend all of your waking
hours reading student writing, it's not --
it's simply unrealistic to expect that we can
use DBQ's for frequent classroom assessment.
They're a great task, but
they're not ideally suited
for quick feedback about student understanding.
And so as we thought about the spectrum
of assessments that were available
to history/social studies
teachers, we were struck by this gap
between the more basic multiple choice
questions and the complex DBQ's.
And we hope to be able to provide something
that could inhabit this middle
ground between the two.
And so in a world of acronyms, we decided
to make our own to fill the middle space,
what we call "history assessments
of thinkings, or HATs."
And so rather than talk a lot about
what HATs are, I'd like to show you one.
To give you an example of one of the
tasks that we created in an effort
to create short document-based assessments
that give us some quick feedback
about specific skills.
This is an assessment that we created
to target very specifically the
historical thinking skill of sourcing.
That is, can students pay attention
to where a document came from?
Who made it?
When? Why?
And for what purpose?
And specifically with this task, we
were really interested in whether
or not students will notice
the date of the document.
So this assessment gives students this image
from the Library of Congress's archives.
The title of the document is,
"First Thanksgiving, 1921."
The document is from 1932, made
by a guy named J.L.G. Ferris.
And the question is, "This painting helps
historians understand the relationship
between the Wampanoag and
the Pilgrim settlers in 1621.
Do you agree or disagree?
Briefly support your answer."
What I'd like you to do is take a
minute or two and just think about,
what do you think a common
student mistake would be?
Not what do you think the idea answer is?
But rather, what do you think a common mistake
would be if you were to give this to students?
What might they answer that might trip them up?
So think about that and then jot down,
what do you think some common student
mistakes with this task would be?
And write those in the comment section.
[ Silence ]
So people have really hit on the issues
of what the most common mistakes are.
Without a doubt.
And we piloted this task now
with thousands of students.
And the types of mistakes that
you are identifying are spot on.
And so I'd like to show you
a few of the responses.
This response is by far the
most common one that we see.
The student wrote, "True."
True as in, it would be a useful source.
"Because you can see how they're
interacting with each other.
Without any picture, you couldn't
really see how Wampanoag Indians
and the Puritans interacted with each other."
So this student is essentially
saying, yes, it's a great source.
Of course it would be useful.
If you didn't show me this picture, how could
I know anything about the First Thanksgiving?
Essentially, a picture's worth a thousand words.
Which is, as several people noted
in the comments, it seems like more
than anything the student is
matching the image of Thanksgiving
to their own beliefs about Thanksgiving.
This matches what I think Thanksgiving looked
like, and as a result it's a useful source.
The second most common type of
response looked more like this one.
The student in this case disagreed.
And they said that it would not
be a useful source for historians.
The student wrote, "As soon as the
settlers arrived, there was mass curiosity
which turned into violence and hatred.
There was never such a "party"
between the two peoples.
They couldn't even understand each other."
And so at first, you know, the
student said something good, right?
They're trying to bring some background
knowledge to bear on the source.
And they're trying to have a
critical examination of the document.
But there are also some errors here.
You know, the students say
that there never such a party.
But we have documentary evidence that there
was a meal held between the two groups.
We can certainly argue about the nature of
the meal, but there's certainly evidence
that the two groups understood each other
and even could understand each other
with Squanto having some exposure
to English and being able to speak.
But regardless, the bigger
issue is that in both the cases,
the students have totally
ignored the date of the document.
And have not addressed the problems that
are associated with using a document
that was created 311 years after the event,
as a source of information about that event.
And to acknowledge the problems that result
from such a gap in time between the date
of production and the event
that it seeks to depict.
And so as a teacher, from those quick
responses I get immediate feedback about whether
or not my students can attend to one aspect
of historical thinking, which is sourcing.
At this point, though, some people say great,
why don't you just make this
into a multiple choice question?
And get rid of all this writing?
It's a lot easier to score
multiple choice questions than it is
to have even short constructed responses.
But what we think is that
there is an enormous amount
that we can learn from short student responses.
So for instance, this student disagreed and
said that it would not be a good source.
So if it was a multiple choice question,
this student would have gotten it right
because they're saying no,
it's not a useful source.
But their reasoning is interesting.
The student wrote, "Painted
by a white person from Europe,
of course they will be extremely biased in
order to bring to light a highly positive image
of the Europeans as to excite
more foreign expeditions.
Because the Indians look
sooo friendly and thankful."
So, although they might have
gotten it right in terms of arguing
that the document would not be a useful one,
their reasoning is clearly pretty suspect.
First, they assume that J.L.G. Ferris
must be white and must be from Europe.
But moreover, they seem to
have ignored the date as well.
Because they seem to think that in
1932 the Europeans were still trying
to excite more foreign expeditions
to the new world.
Deeply problematic.
But as a teacher, there's something
good going on here as well.
The student is acknowledging that the author
of a document -- the artist in this case --
influences the content of the document.
That's what we want students to do.
We want them to think about the way in which
the author carefully shapes the content
of a document.
So if this is my student, I can say, "I'm really
glad that you're paying attention to the way
in which the author influences the document.
But we also really need to pay
attention to the date of a document.
And that's going to be a crucial piece
of information to think about as well."
We also in some cases see
really polished responses.
This student wrote -- and it was an
eighth grader, as a matter of fact --
wrote, "This painting was drawn 311
years after the actual event happened.
There's no evidence of historical accuracy,
as we do not know if the artist
did research before painting this,
or if he just drew what is a
stereotypical Pilgrim and Indian painting."
Really impressive for an eighth grader.
I did not have a lot of tenth graders when I
was teaching who could formulate this response.
And the student has nicer handwriting than I do.
But what is striking is, the student has both
identified the danger of using a document
so far removed from the event that it depicts.
But they've also acknowledged that if we knew
more about what the artist did in advance
of creating the document, it might
change the way that we think about it.
The document -- this answer also
shows something that we've seen over
and over again with these responses.
Which is, there isn't a clear developmental
trajectory in terms of student thinking.
In other words, it's not as
though seniors can engage,
only high school seniors can
engage in this type of thinking.
In fact, as this eighth grader demonstrates,
many students can engage
in this type of thinking.
Perhaps not surprisingly, what we found is
it's the students who've been taught to engage
in historical thinking who do it.
And it's the students who have not who struggle.
So for instance, we've given this task to
high school seniors who have gotten fives
on the AP U.S. History exam, and they've
missed the date of the Thanksgiving painting.
And I don't mean that in any way
as a knock against those students.
I'm very confident that with a few minutes
of instruction they would see
the importance of the date.
They just haven't been taught to look
carefully at the dates of documents.
That, especially in the past, has not
been heavily emphasized in AP testing.
In contrast, we've seen fifth graders who
have come up with really strong responses.
Not quite as polished, and the
handwriting's not quite as good as this one.
But we've seen fifth graders
do it because they've been
in classrooms where this has been emphasized.
However, none of these tasks are
based on only a single document.
Instead, they are -- we intend
them to be flexible
so that we can make multiple versions of them.
This is the exact same assessment.
But instead of a Thanksgiving
painting, we have an engraving
of the signing of the Mayflower Compact.
And again, there's a big
gap in time between the date
of the document and the event that it depicts.
And so if I'm a teacher I could
use the Thanksgiving assessment
at the beginning of the school year.
And then give it back to students
and give them some feedback
about what strong responses look like.
And then I could give them another one a few
weeks later, like this one, to see whether
or not they've really internalized
those ideas and they have been able
to track the crucial nature of considering
the source when evaluating documents.
So when we think about HATs,
we have made them to be short,
so that they can be done
quickly in five or ten minutes.
And they target specific content and skills.
So in this case it's very much about sourcing,
and one aspect of sourcing,
the date of the document.
So that we can get quick feedback
about students' ability with them.
Similarly, it gives evidence
of student thinking.
So as teachers we get some immediate information
that we can use to shape our next steps
and it doesn't take us hours to get it.
We can quickly even flip through, even if we
don't give students detailed written feedback,
we can get a temperature for our classroom.
Which will shape our next steps as teachers.
And hopefully they're more accessible, right?
That if some of our students are
not yet ready for the really great,
rich challenged of a document-based question,
that we can have them complete these shorter
tasks in the building block towards some
of those more complex types of assessments.
Often at this point after looking at
that assessment, some people will say,
so do you guys just care about skills
and you don't care about content at all?
And they couldn't be further from the truth.
When we constructed our domain of what we
were seeking to assess, historical thinking,
we place historical knowledge as one of the
three main pillars of historical thinking.
Students need to know content in order
to engage with historical documents.
And then there's evaluation of evidence.
Students need to consider the
source and place it in context.
And corroborate it, to consider
multiple documents,
and to look for points of
similarity and difference.
In order to build a historical argument.
And so other assessments that we've created
address historical content very directly.
This is an assessment that's about students'
knowledge of the Civil Rights Movement.
And it would be an assessment you'd give
after you had taught students
about the Civil Rights Movement.
And it draws on two letters
from the archives of the NAACP.
And the first letter, both written
to the executive director of NAACP.
The first letter says, "Before I received your
letter today, I had been in to the President.
And he said the difficulty is that
it is unconstitutional, apparently,
for the federal government to
step into the lynching situation.
The President feels that lynching is
a question of education in the states.
I'm deeply troubled about the whole
situation, as it seems to be a terrible thing
to stand by and let it continue."
Students then read a second document,
also from the NAACP about conditions
at a previously all-white school.
The letter reads, "Conditions are yet
pretty rough in the school for the children.
The treatment of the children had been
getting steadily worse for the last two weeks
in the form of kicking, spitting,
and general abuse.
As a result of our visit, stronger measures
are being taken against the white students
who are guilty of committing these offenses.
The President of the United States was
very much concerned about the crisis."
And instead of asking students a question
like, what was the year of Brown v. Board?
Or when did lynching reach
its peak in the United States?
We asked a very basic question,
which is, which letter came first?
We didn't give them the dates
of the documents in this case.
Instead we wanted them to use their knowledge
of the Civil Rights Movement in order
to place these documents in context.
Which one came first?
And what from the document provided them the
necessary information to answer the question?
So if students don't know about the Civil
Rights Movement, they might answer it this way.
Student wrote, "Letter B
was likely written first,
because letter B is addressing
the unsegregation of schools,
and letter A is about the
response to the issue -- lynching."
And there's a certain cause-and-effect
logic going on here.
But it's simply historically incorrect
that following the integration of schools,
although there's some violence, there is not
widespread lynching that happens as a result.
The student does not have a grasp of the
Civil Rights Movement and the way in which,
over the course of the 20th Century, the
federal government became increasingly involved
in acting on the behalf of African-Americans.
And intervening in the Civil Rights Movement.
Moreover, that the lynching was much more a
problem in the first part of the 20th Century
when it reached a sort of critical mass.
In contrast, the integration
of schools happened later.
And so as a teacher we can
get some quick feedback about,
do my students have the broad
narrative of the Civil Rights Movement?
Do they understand the broad
contours of the Movement rather than,
do they know about specific names or dates?
Although those are important,
this is a different type of task
that assesses their broader
knowledge of the movement as a whole.
As with the Thanksgiving assessment,
we can make parallels that focus
on other important moments
and events in history.
This one is about immigration.
And so this shows an excerpt from a newspaper
article that says, "It's my firm belief
that an exclusion act even more stringent
than the present one should be passed
in the matter of the Japanese immigrant.
The Chinese are dangerous enough,
but the Japanese would drive
all competition out of business.
It is the stern duty of the American
citizen, particularly of those
of us upon this western coast,
to scrutinize this even
and then suppress it with
appropriate legislation."
And the second document says, "There had been
4700 emigrants landed on the previous Thursday,
and we learned on Monday that 10, 035
had arrived on the Saturday and Sunday,
principally Germans, each possessed of a small
capital, and all ready to proceed instantly
to the various German settlements
in the interior without staying
to waste their means in New York.
The Custom-house officer's
duty was a mere form."
So again, the students have an understanding
of when did exclusion acts take place.
And in what place and time did different waves
of immigration occur in the United States.
All of these assessments are available
on beyondthebubble.stanford.edu.
And there is a very short video that
you can watch right now at this link
that gives you a little taste of why we've
constructed materials the way we have.
And then after you watch that, we'll take
a very quick tour through the website.
And then we will take some questions.
>> Imagine if real-life decisions
were like a multiple choice exam.
>> First question, "To surprise the
British troops in Trenton, should I A),
dress my troops up as a marching band
and offer to play a free concert?
B), Hide my troops in a giant horse and
present it as a victory gift to the British?
C), Cross the icy Delaware in a rickety rowboat?
D) Stay in my tent because it's cold
outside, and let someone else deal with them?
>> Seems ridiculous, right?
Essentially, that's what
multiple choice tests do.
They penalize kids for not knowing
facts that are ripped out of context.
On the opposite end of the spectrum are
document-based questions requiring students
to analyze and write a college-level
essay based on ten documents.
But what if your students haven't learned
to analyze one document, let alone ten?
As an educator, do you have any other options?
Now you do.
Beyond the Bubble was developed by
the Stanford History Education Group.
And unlocks the vast digital
archive of the Library of Congress
to create a new generation
of history assessments.
Our easy to use assessments capture
students' knowledge in action.
Rather than their recall of disconnected facts.
We call our exercises History
Assessments of Thinking, or HATs.
HATs ask students to engage
in historical reasoning
as they critically examine primary sources.
Most HATs take just a few minutes to complete.
And they're easy to score.
They also come with interactive scoring rubrics,
samples of student work, and Going Deeper videos
that extend your understanding
of these assessments.
Your students' short written responses
to these HATs will give you access
to what they are really thinking.
Of course, there's always the alternative.
>> Are you sure we weren't supposed
to dress up as a marching band?
>> No, I picked A last time; it has to be C.
>> I'd have preferred D; I'm freezing.
I think I got some ice in my knickers.
>> Everyone be quiet.
I picked C, and that's the answer.
[ Water noises ]
>> So all the materials are on
beyondthebubble@stanford.edu.
On the top of the home page,
it says Assessments.
That's where you'll find all of the materials.
And so you'll see they are
organized by assessment type.
So for instance, you'll see
the First Thanksgiving here.
And then below that there are
the parallel versions of it.
So there's the signing of the Mayflower Compact.
There's a brief description of the assessment.
There are words that are underlined
in red; if you hover your cursor
over that you'll get a brief
definition of what that word means.
There's a link to the Common
Core standard that goes along
with those materials highlighted
for the History/Social Studies.
It certain addresses lots of ELA ones as well.
On the right-hand side of the page once
you go into a particular assessment,
you'll see that there is a link
to the PDF of the document.
So if you want to hand it out to students --
I will note that you need to be logged
into the website in order to download it.
Logging into the website is completely free;
you just need to make an account on the website.
Or if you've already made an account on
sheg.stanford.edu, it will work there as well.
You can see everything without being logged in,
but we require people to log
in to download materials.
Just so we can track who's using the resources.
And then there's a link to the document
in the Library of Congress's archive.
So you can see the original document as well.
Then going on the right-hand side of the page,
you'll see that there is a
rubric for each of the tasks.
And so the rubric is a basis three-level rubric.
Proficient: Student has gotten it dead on.
Emergent is, student's done something
good but it's not all the way there.
And then Basic is, the student's
missed the boat;
they haven't really understood
the question just yet.
And each of the rubric levels
is linked to student work.
And so all of the same student responses
that we showed before are on the website.
And there are these little blue
thumb tacks on the answers.
And if you roll over them, they're
just prefanatations [assumed]
about what we see going on with the assessment.
And that is, an example of the responses
that we've chosen to include are examples
of the common responses we've seen in piloting
these with hundreds and thousands of students.
So as a teacher it will give you some
really quick feedback about the kinds
of responses you might expect to see.
You can also show it to students to demonstrate
what exemplary responses might look like.
and then finally, each type of assessment --
assessment types, so Thanksgiving for instance,
has a short streaming video
that goes with it that talks
about how you might use these
materials in your class
or how you might create your
own that you can watch.
And then finally, actually, there's
also a comment section so you can --
if you have some thoughts about the task,
or you'd like to see what other teachers
have said, you can go there as well.
But I also want to point out that
we certainly don't have any monopoly
on the creation of assessment materials.
And in fact we hope the teachers
will create their own materials.
We see them as templates for
other people to create materials.
And the Library of Congress offers an
incredible set of resources in order to do so.
And so some of our favorite Library
of Congress resources are available
on the main page of the Library, loc.gov.
A really great, really a wealth
of materials are available
on the teachers' page, loc.gov/teachers.
Great primary source sets.
Blog quotes as to how you
might use these materials.
The ability to search by standard
or by state, all available there.
So although loc.gov is incredible, it can
also sometimes feel a little overwhelming
because there's so much.
And loc.gov/teachers has really
great curated sets of materials.
And then chroniclingamerica.loc.gov, I
think, is one of the coolest websites around.
And somebody who spent far too much time in the
basements of libraries going through microfilm,
the chroniclingamerica has thousands and
thousands of newspapers totally digitized.
And you can search by keyword,
by date, by location.
And you get the full pdf of
the pages of the newspapers,
even after they've been fully
searchable by key word.
So if you want to know how the sinking of
the Titanic was covered in Missoula, Montana,
you can go look for that and then compare
it to how it was covered in Washington, DC.
It's a really fabulous resource.
And then also see all of the ads that
go alongside the newspaper stories.
And then finally, World Digital Library is an
incredible resource for world history teachers.
And it is a project that the Library of
Congress has undertaken in partnership
with cultural institutions around the world.
And it offers world history
materials and documents
from various museums and
libraries around the globe.
And you can search by time period, you
can search by geographic location as well.
And they continue to add materials all the time;
it's a really great resource
that continues to grow.
And so finally I'll just
leave you with a few thoughts
about how you might create your own assessments.
You know, the first thing we always do is
to choose what we're trying to measure.
Then make a rough draft.
And then take a moment and
do what we did when we looked
at those multiple choice questions and DBQ's.
What is this actually measuring?
Do the analysis before you
even give it to students.
What are we actually measuring?
If I'm trying to make an assessment
about sourcing and my student has
to write a long paragraph, then maybe it's
more assessment of writing than sourcing.
And pilot it; try it out with
your students and see how it goes.
And then revise it.
We've never made an assessment that
works perfectly the first time we do it;
we need to adjust it after we've done it.
And then tweak it as you go.
And see how it works.
And if you make something
great, please share it with us.
We love to hear from teachers
who are using our materials.
And that's everything from, I'm wondering
how to get logged onto your website,
to I made this cool assessment;
what do you think?
Or, I'm trying to use these
materials in my classroom.
Please do reach out to us; we really do want
to be in touch with teachers and support you
in any way we can as you're using our materials
or you're navigating the Library's archives.
And I would just point out the last two items
on this list are the SHEG's twitter
handle and the Facebook page.
That we're adding new materials
all the time to our website.
And we don't send out emails to
our email list when we do that.
But we do post on twitter and
Facebook when new resources go up.
And then I would also just point out, as
Kathy put it in the chat section just now is
that the Library also offers an incredible
set of professional development resources
on the teacher's page, and
she put the link there.
So that's a great resource too.
So thank you so much for
spending some time with me
on a school night; I know that's not easy to do.
And I look forward to some questions now.
>> Oh, Joel, we have lots of questions.
Thank you so much for the
wonderful presentation.
So I'm just going to dive right into
them so we can get in as many as we can.
Jodi -- and I'm not sure I'm going
to pronounce her name correctly,
Montebiano [phonetic] asked the question, "How
do you correct errors in student thinking?"
And then Chrissy Jacobs chimed in, "You
can't really correct a student's thinking.
You can help them construct
knowledge by giving them opportunities
to notice inconsistencies, etcetera."
And then Amber, who was in the last session with
Sam, noted that that was basically her question.
She's new to her district
and it's been a struggle.
So how can you address the errors when
looking at the students' thinking?
>> Really, really good questions.
You know, and I think our hope is that these
types of tasks provide opportunities to surface.
What are some of the misconceptions
or errors in student thinking?
So that we can address them as a whole class.
You know, we work with a teacher in
San Francisco Unified School District.
And she gave the Thanksgiving
task on the first day of school.
Because she knows that almost none
of her students will get it right.
She doesn't even grade the task;
she just has everybody do it.
And she knows that probably 90% of the
students will say it's a great resource.
And then instead of even spending the time
to mark up all of them, she goes over,
"What does a strong response look like?"
So that it's an opportunity to
build student understanding of,
it's really important to look at the date.
And in this class we're going to
care about where documents came from.
And so I think that's one way.
And then the other is, you know, of the
idea of formative assessment is to be able
to provide students with a goal
of what we're trying to do.
Ultimately this is what we
want to be able to do in terms
of our thinking, we want to source documents.
And that the tasks are a way
for us to identify the gap
between where we ultimately want our
students to be and where they currently are.
And it's a way for students to
see where they currently are,
and have a sense of where they can go next.
And so I think there are ways in which
we can do some with individual feedback.
But also given, you know, the constraints
of if you have 150 kids in your classes,
you can't write even short responses on
all of these types of tasks all the time.
So figuring out other ways to provide
constructive, meaningful feedback that's based
on sort of the overall place your class is in.
And then if there are a few students who
are, you know, way above or way below,
that you can work with them
individually but have tried to figure
out how we can help move the
whole class forward in general.
>> That's great.
Thank you.
Rita had sent a question, but I
think you've already answered it,
saying, "Where can we find the HATs?"
And we provided the link to Beyond the Bubble.
And you explained some of the
functionality of that site.
So I thank you for that.
Chas Chastain asks a question,
"Does the way the opening statement
in the DBQ is worded influence students
to believe the document is more credible?"
>> Yes, you know, I think we always are
trying to be really cognizant of the way
in which the wording of tasks
may influence students.
And we try certainly quite hard not to do that.
And one way that we do that is, we do
think-aloud interviews with students
where we sit down and ask them to think
out loud as they complete our tasks.
And sometimes we find that, you
know, the students read the tasks
in a very different way than we intended it.
And then we tweak it as a result.
So, you know, our hope is
certainly that we don't want
to be influencing students one way or the other.
But it's an ongoing process.
So it's possible, but our hope is
they're not unduly being influenced.
>> Okay, I have a question.
I'm going to make it a two-fer.
But they come from two different folks.
Veronica Zermino asks, "Will Stanford move
into creating something like this for --
I mean Beyond the Bubble -- for other subjects
other than Social Studies or History?"
And Crissy Jacobs asked a question,
"What kind of issues do you see come
up in a pilot that would need to be tweaked?"
I don't know if they belong in the same
bucket, but they're not far from each other.
>> Yes, those are really
two excellent questions.
We are currently working on creating tasks
that assess how students
interpret information online.
That, for instance, are students
able to recognize
that a new story is sponsored
content, that it's essentially an ad?
Or will they ask, where did the
Facebook post that makes a claim
about that Denali means Black
Power in Kenyan, for instance?
Will they ask whether or not
they trust that Facebook post?
So we're trying to create some short
tasks that move us into the realm
of assessing students' ability
to interpret information online.
So that's a new effort that's
beyond just History.
>> That's great.
And I think we have one last question.
I'm going to leave it with Jody's question, "Is
it effective to teach by direct instruction?
Or do we need to veer away from this?"
>> I mean, I think you could do some of both.
You know, I think that it's quite possible
to do some direct instruction, you know,
we're going to give this task out and we will
all answer the question and then I'm going
to provide some instruction about
how would I answer this question?
What does an ideal response look like?
You know, that too often our expert thinking
as teachers remains invisible to our students.
And so more opportunities for us to make
our thinking visible, of thinking aloud
and doing some cognitive modeling of
what strong responses would look like.
Or how do we interrogate historical
sources certainly can be useful.
That's not an argument to say that
it should all be direct instruction.
We also want our students to wrestle
with these documents, ultimately.
And that any cognitive modeling should
be followed up with opportunities
for students to practice on their own.
And to begin to develop their ability to
engage in this type of historical thinking,
and reasoning and writing independently.
So I think it's going to be a mix of both.
>> Alright, thank you, Joel.
And I see more questions coming in.
And they're excellent, but we are past our time.
So I am going to invite you to make sure that
you get Joel's contact information there.
It's breakstone@stanford.edu.
His twitter feed is @joelbreakstone.
You can contact him through the
SHEG website, sheg.stanford.edu.
The url beyondthebubble is there as well.
And the Stanford History Education
Group has a page on Facebook.
I will make sure to get Joel
the chat from today.
And so he will have your questions.
A couple of items before
we break for the evening.
Please give us your feedback.
We have a very short three-question survey.
It helps us program for the future.
We will send you an email
within the week about how
to get a certificate for
completing this session.
And you'll receive an email
within five business days.
And for those who asked the question about,
where can I get some information about how
to get students to analyze them,
please go visit us at loc.gov/teachers.
We have tons of information to help you in
getting students to analyze primary sources.
Joel, thank you so much for
this great presentation.
This will be something that I know
will be treasured in the recordings.
I know that our folks got
a lot out of this tonight.
So thank you all for staying
with us at the end of a long day.
We do appreciate your time.
Joel, thank you very much.
>> You're very welcome.
Thanks so much.
And thanks to all of you who
came out and participated.
It was a pleasure.
>> Terrific.
I'm going to end the recording,
and I'm going to end the meeting.
Thank you very much.
>> Goodnight.
[ Silence ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.